merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre après le nouveau drame
que vient de vivre notre pays
permettez-moi une pensée pour les
proches de Dominique Bernard ainsi que
pour les blessés dont le courageux
employé qui s'est dressé face à la
barbarie mais aussi à l'égard des
professeurs angoissés d'être devenu des
cibles mais madame la Première ministre
nous sommes législateurs comptable de
l'efficacité des réponses apporté à ces
drames alors pourquoi annoncer
l'expulsion des étrangers inscrits au au
fsprt pardon maintenant et pas avant
alors que sur 25 attentats depuis 2017
la moitié était le fait d'étranger dont
3/4 de surcroix clandestin et pour
beaucoup quasiment la moitié suivi pour
fondamentalisme islamique pourquoi ne
pas expulser tous les étrangers
islamiste qu'ils soi en situation légale
ou illégale car ils sont avant tout des
ennemis de la France pourquoi ne pas
étendre les expulsions à ceux qui ont
commis des crimes et des délites graves
à leur sortie de
prisonam
criminel et délinquants qu'est-ce qui
justifie de garder ces personnes sur
notre
sol pourquoi en trompant les Français se
servir de l'attentat terroriste d'aras
pour vendre votre future loi d'imig sur
l'immigration en faisant croire que le
droit actuel ne nous permettrait pas
d'expulser le terroriste en question au
motif qu'il est arrivé et en France
avant 13 ans il a résidé alors que le
droit vous permettait évidemment de le
faire comme l'indique le plus clairement
du monde la article 6313 du cza article
d'ailleurs totalement compatible avec
l'article 33 alinéa 2 de la Convention
de Genève relative au statut des
réfugiés pour résumer pourquoi faire
croire que votre incapacité à juguler le
fondamentalisme islamiste est la
conséquence des lois que vous auriez
d'ailleurs pu changer depuis 6 ans alors
que votre impuissance est avant tout la
conséquence de votre absence de volonté
réelle et probablement d'une forme de
crainte qui vous empêche de lutter
efficacement contre les idéologies
islamistes qui se répande et tu dans
notre
pays la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Marine Le Pen vendredi
dernier un professeur de lettres du
lycée gambeta d'aras Dominique Bernard a
été sauvagement assassiné par un
terroriste islamiste en écho tragique à
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty il y a 3 ans
ces moments ces moments s'il vous plaît
ces moments graves son révélateur il
nous
oblige il nous oblige d'abord à un peu
de dignité madame la Présidente Le Pen
depuis 2022 à chaque crise vous vous
êtes illustré par votre silence
aujourd'hui le naturel revient au Galot
alors que la France est en deuil alors
que l'école est touchée alors qu'un
enseignant est mort vous vous lancez
dans des polémiques politiciennes vous
jetez des des anathèmes vous multipliez
les mises en cause alors que le
terrorisme frappe et que la situation
internationale est préoccupante vous
refusez ce matin même explicitement
l'unité de notre pays madame la
Présidente Le Pen dans les moments
graves je crois pour ma part dans la
cohésion nationale et dans l'action et
avec mon gouvernement j'y suis déterminé
face aux menaces qui pèent sur notre
pays nous sommes fermes fermes dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme et depuis
2017 nous avons accordé des moyens
inédits à nos services de renseignement
et à notre justice des moyens qui ont
permis de déjouer 43 attentats depuis 6
ans ferme dès le 7 octobre et l'attaque
terroriste contre Israël en renforçant
la sécurité des lieux sensibles et en
procédant à l'interpellation de plus de
100 ind individu en lien direct avec des
actes antisémites ou d'apologie du
terrorisme ferme et réactif pour la
sécurité de nos éccolees dès vendredi
j'ai réhaussé la posture Vigi pirate la
sécurité des écoles a été renforcée et
sur décision du Président de la
République 7000 militaires ont été
mobilisés dans le cadre de l'opération
sentinelle ferme face à l'immigration
illégale et face aux étrangers
radicalisés sur notre territoire en 6
ans madame la présidente Le Pen plus de
900 étrangers fichés au fsprt ont été
expulsés donc quand nous pouvons les
expulser nous le faisons être ferme
enfin c'est renforcer notre arsenal
juridique élever les freins législatifs
à l'exculsion des étrangers qui
représentent une menace pour notre pays
c'est l'un des objectifs du projet de
loi immigration que porte le ministre de
l'Intérieur
Géral quandsens polémique je pour part
dire mon soutien aux agents de nos
services de renseignement aux enquêteurs
à nos policiers à nos gendarmes à nos
militair mobilisé dans la lutte contre
le
terrorisme et devant vous une nouvelle
fois je l'affirme face au drame notre
force c'est notre unité c'est le respect
de nos valeurs républicaines c'est la
cohésion nationale avec mon gouvernement
nous y vrons je vous merci merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre Tam